Speaker 1: Hey, I have something unbelievable
for you.
Last week in the morning, Friday morning,
Fox News was gleefully gleefully predicting
a disastrous jobs report.
They were doing coverage all morning.
It's going to be terrible.
They were rooting for our failure.
Which they say we do, which of course we don't
they?
They were rooting against America and then
the jobs report came in and it was fantastic.
It was it was an incredible jobs report that
we actually had.
U.S. added over 450000 jobs in January 2020
to strong demand at restaurants, retailers,
mail and parcel delivery.
Leisure and hospitality added more than 150000
jobs.
Retail added $61.
I mean, just incredible numbers.
And Fox had to then just go silent.
You have to see this.
Here is the morning on Fox before the jobs
Speaker 2: report and the next hour the January
jobs report will be released and it could
be the worst in years.
The House has been bracing for a bad number.
It could be a loss of 300000 jobs.
How is the White House going to put a happy
face on that wall?
Speaker 1: The real question is, how are you
going to put a sad face on the incredible
numbers we got?
It thinks
Speaker 3: that we might see a loss of hundreds
of thousands of
Speaker 2: jobs.
It could be a morning of pain because just
about twenty eight minutes from right now,
the January jobs report is going to be released
by the Bureau of Labor and Whatnot.
Projection is for an already low one hundred
and fifty thousand jobs added.
But ADP, the company that processes payrolls,
says to expect three hundred and one thousand
jobs lost be a half a million jobs swing the
wrong way.
Speaker 3: The Biden administration bracing
for yet another economic class.
We're going to hear the January jobs report
Speaker 2: soon after it didn't work out that
way.
The jobs report
Speaker 3: just released the US adding four
hundred and sixty seven thousand jobs,
Speaker 1: so they they did ultimately report
on the numbers.
And many of these people going completely
and totally silent.
Some funny one funny graphic that they had
was this like completely negative, catastrophic,
more job losses and huge red font.
February 4th, 2022.
And of course, it didn't happen.
Now you can always ask questions like, Well,
what is the quality of these jobs?
What are the wages of these?
We always ask these questions.
This is not a Partizan thing for me.
When I was the first to tell you during the
Trump administration, the economy was mostly
doing very well.
Whether it had anything to do with Trump was
a real question.
Whether these jobs numbers have anything to
do with Biden is a completely fair question.
But the rooting against America, which I always
thought they said we did even though they
do it is just another instance of projection
and this is completely beyond parody.
This is later on.
Steve Doocy asking Stuart Varney, How did
everybody get it so wrong?
Speaker 3: All right, the January jobs report
is in White House should be happy about that.
Step over to you.
Speaker 2: All right.
Thank you very much, Karl.
Let's bring in Stuart Varney, host of Varney
and Company, an American built on FOX Business.
Stuart.
You know, this morning we were projecting
what one estimate was one hundred and fifty
thousand, or it could have been three hundred
thousand in the hole, right close to half
a million.
How did everybody get this so wrong?
Well, you're right.
Speaker 4: Everybody did get this chronically
wrong.
I'm not sure I can really explain why we've
got this explosion of four hundred and sixty
seven thousand jobs because it does run counter
to what we were expecting.
We thought that COVID or Omicron in particular,
would be keeping millions of people at home.
They would not be at work and that will be
jobs lost.
Speaker 1: Now what's funny is they didn't
originally think that like they downplayed
Macron, they downplayed reports from Fauci
and others.
We could have 15 20 percent of the population
out sick.
But now they're saying, no, I mean, based
on all that stuff, which we rejected for weeks,
we were expecting it to be bad.
Speaker 4: Well, it didn't work out that way.
I'm sure that millions of people are at home
suffering from Akron, and these figures were
taken in January.
But the overall number was still way up that
I can explain one thing here.
The unemployment rate went up from three point
nine to four percent.
Speaker 1: It went up right now.
So that actually isn't necessarily a bad thing.
Now I we've talked about and again, you fact
check me, go back and look at how I cover
jobs, OK?
It's not a Partizan thing for me.
Sometimes the unemployment rate goes up because
more people are starting to look for jobs.
When you are actively looking for a job, you
were considered unemployed.
If you stop looking, you are no longer considered
unemployed.
This was the case under Reagan, under Clinton.
This is just this is what it is, and I don't
play these games where I ignore how these
things are measured, depending on who's in
the White House.
I don't care about political party what sometimes
when the economy is getting better, more people
say I now want to reenter the workforce and
they become considered.
Actively unemployed.
So it doesn't tell us much that the unemployment
rate went from, I think, 3.9 to 4.0 it and
we're going to continue covering this in the
same empirical way that we've been from the
beginning, but how sad they were over at Fox
that the jobs report was good.
Let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman
and we'll be right back.
The David Pakman show is sponsored directly
by viewers and listeners who sign up and join
Packman dot com, we do an extra show every
single day for our members, called the bonus
show.
Remember that Alex Jones hates the bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: I can think of no greater endorsement
for the world famous bonus show than Alex
Jones being against it.
Speaker 2: Thank your lucky stars every day.
You're not David Pakman.
Speaker 1: You can sign up at Dutch Edge.
Isn't it crazy that this is my job?
You can sign up at join Packman dot com and
use the coupon code.
Wow.